[Music]  the truth is when producers wanted me to  be sexy I'd always put some absurd spin  on it that made me feel like I was still  in control  [Applause]  [Music]  what happened in the last five years  real fans probably knew deep down that  there was something going on  paranoia fear body pain xiety I go  through every word touching me all day  and talking at me all day total silence  and all these people will leave and then  I'll be alone I didn't feel good enough  and I dunno that's the good part  I have chased this me for five years but  when I feel the adrenaline of my music  and my fans I had a [ __ ] job  [Music]  my family is the most important thing in  my life Oh Joanna she died when he was  19  I can always bring my past with me but I  can never go back  you got to leave yourself behind  [Music]  I want to do the opposite of what  everyone says I'm going to do there  really isn't anything better than this  [Applause]  [Music]  ladies  oh do we tell them  [Music]